well I played out differently so there's
been an interesting series of
developments in regards to the Cassie
and one of the characters in the Hellboy
reboot and this wasn't something that I
was planning to talk about I had
actually kind of deliberately left it
off the most recent episode of the
podcast go home Hollywood you're drunk
part of the Council of geeks podcast fee
give it a listen
just cuz I wasn't sure I had anything to
say about it and and that particular
podcast is is more like hard and I kind
of didn't want to open a can of worms
but it's turned into a bigger story at
least in terms of people reacting to it
and how much traction is getting than I
had expected
so given that I've talked about race
recasting before I might as well step
right on this landmine again so in case
you you haven't been following the actor
Edie screen screen I don't know how to
pronounce his last name
at this point best known for debt as the
villain in Deadpool and also as the
original Daario naharis
before he was recast because he left to
do other projects he was cast in a role
in the Hellboy reboot that is currently
being worked on now the character he was
casted as a character named ben de mio
who is a character I'm not familiar with
I it's been a long time since I've
picked up a Hellboy or BPRD issue or
volume so I don't know if he was
introduced back when I was still reading
it or if he's new or I just don't
remember him but uh apparently Ben is a
Asian character he is written as such
that is how he appears in the comics and
edy screen is not he's very clearly is
not and when the caste was announced
there was not a completely unexpected if
you've been following these kinds of
things lately outcry about that casting
now that's not particularly unusual at
this point it's actually it's it's
gotten to the point where
Studios need to stop acting surprised
when this happens but it was the
response to what happened that I find
really interesting and I think worth
talking about
there was a basically the official story
that came out and I'm gonna I'm using
that word for a reason I'm gonna kind of
address that that as I go along was that
ed skrein himself voluntarily said I'm
not gonna play this role stepped away
from the project issued a statement
saying that he had not appreciated the
the impact and the concerns about him
playing this role and he thought the
most respectful thing he could do was to
not play the part after he did that the
producers and the makers of the movie
released their own statement basically
back him up saying we respect as
decision we're going to cast racially
appropriate and move forward and this is
all really interesting I mean for the
first thing I'm pretty sure it's the
first time certainly the first time I
can remember at least since I've been
paying attention to this kind of stuff
where an outcry about the racial
recasting actually resulted in that
casting being changed I'm sure there's
some way I may not be the first time
it's ever happened but it certainly
feels like the first time in recent
memory because generally the line from
Studios producers etc the people who
make the casting decisions is well we
have to cast a white actor because you
know there aren't actors of whatever the
ethnic group is of you know sufficient
stature for us to cast them and and
that's and that's an argument that I
think is holding up less and less as
time goes on especially as the outcry
against it is becoming greater and
greater you have to wonder if the PR
nightmare is worth whatever boost a box
office they think they're getting that I
think arguably they're probably not even
really getting in the first place
because I don't think movie box office
numbers are nearly is driven by star
powers they
used to be but in any case it in terms
of that theory it's more defensible and
from a strictly bottom-line dollar
box-office pragmatic standpoint
defensible when you're talking about the
lead role will you talking about a
supporting character why can't you have
a non-white ethnicity is the supporting
gear so that kind of argument doesn't
hold up
but it's still the argument that would
always get made from studios from
producers and from those types of people
so the fact that that isn't what
happened here that's interesting the
fact that it appears that it is the
actor himself who made the decision to
step down which I do kind of want to
address that specifically because if
that is actually how it went down then
tip the hat to him because and I think I
think there's a decent chance that is
how it went down because at this point
ed skrein has a pretty solid career
going he's not a huge name but he's
working begg'd very regularly he's
working in you know recognizable roles
and I he he can afford to let this one
job go cuz I'm pretty sure he can line
up something else really quickly so I I
think there's a pretty good chance that
this is in fact how went down that being
said if it ever transpires that what
actually happened is that the studio
responded to the outcry by terminating
him but telling him you need to tell
people it was your idea to leave we
can't tell people that were firing you
if that ever transpires to be the case
that I'm gonna call massive BS on and
call BS on the studio not for caving to
pressure but for obfuscating what
they're doing I mean if if you're going
to you know change or alter something
because of how the fans reacted own up
to that I mean that's what
thing happens all the time with relation
to other things remember back with the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles reboot the
one that Michael Bay was producing they
were gonna be aliens but when the fans
left they change that and shredder was
going to be this white guy in fans went
and they change that so you know you can
cave to pressure just cop that you're
caving depression don't throw don't make
an actor throw himself onto the sword I
have no evidence and I'm not I don't
even think I believe that's what
happened but I just want to address that
as a possibility because I think it is a
possibility but by and large I find this
whole turn of events to be kind of
encouraging because you know there's
there's always a lot that gets kicked up
on all sides when a character is their
race as well their race is changes as
genders change any kinds of things but
for the purposes of this video let's
just stick to race and that exactly you
know there's a lot of stuff that gets
kicked up when it is a traditionally you
know non-white part given to a white
actor or a traditionally white part
given to a non-white actor and again I'm
not talking about either one of those
being more valid or another I really
don't want to deal with that I'm just
acknowledging the fact that regardless
of which way it goes there is always
going to be an outcry and there always
is I think something that is just in
general going to help in terms of
settling things down is just just cast
to the original character description in
terms of when you're adapting something
I think and again that's not me saying
that there will never be a valid reason
to change the ethnicity of a character I
did a whole video about why you know
before the iron fist TV show came out I
thought on balance it probably would
have been a better idea to recast Danny
as an asian-american character but that
was very specific to that case I had
reasons for thinking that was the best
in that specific case but I think in
broad terms more in the case of
non-white characters you need to leave
them as non-white and the thing is
regardless of how you feel about it you
know the reasons for when it happens or
is considered that a white characters
change to another ethnicity the simple
fact is is that there isn't a white
representation problem in terms of
numbers of roles given to actors in
terms of how these characters are
written there is a representation
problem with other ethnic minorities
when it comes to movies made in
Hollywood so it's just a really bad look
to take away the few roles written to
not be white that there are and when you
do adapt it works now you know things
like ghost in the shell and and Death
Note I think are a little bit trickier
because they are in fact adaptations of
a story from a completely different
culture and you're actually moving the
location to America so you know why
wouldn't you cast you know to reflect
where it's set now and I mean I
mentioned ghost in the shell' that one
really did it wrong in terms of the
Cassie and then they tried to address it
in the movie made worse but and the
waters get muddy or when you're dealing
with that kind of adaptations because
you know what you really do look at a
case by case for you know why did
something like ghost in the shell' do it
so wrong whereas something like The
Departed which is based on a nation film
I believe a Hong Kong film and then you
know set in Boston and cast pretty much
all white people
why didn't I did that one do it right so
you know the it muddies the waters when
it's that kind of adaptation but Hellboy
is an American comic book it's an
American property being made by an
American studio that has some diversity
in its cast in the source material so
not keeping that is just a bad idea at
this point and and I like that the
makers of this movie seemed to recognize
oh okay we made a mistake we're sorry
and I'm hoping that the metrics are
gonna shift to break Studios out of that
mentality that I mentioned before where
they think what we have to catch white
people because all the biggest stars are
white people and again I I would
personally make the argument we're just
not in a star driven entertainment
economy anymore I'm not saying stars
have no value but they don't drive you
know box office the way that they used
to and beyond that it's being shown by
the repeated and consistent pressure
that gets put on you know Studios
directors etc when these sorts of ethnic
characters are taken away and not
allowed to be played by ethnic actors
that that outcry from early films was
not a fluke it's going to keep happening
every time they do it and I'm hoping
that the realization of that will make
them really start to go oh okay
we really can't justify this move
anymore or or maybe at the very least
you know maybe we get a boost to the box
office but it's not worth the crap we're
gonna have to deal with and I that is
that as sort of my hope coming out of
this particular thing is that this
reaction to the outcry which I think
again assuming that the official line on
what happened is in fact what happened I
think that it was well handled by IDI
screen and by the people behind the
Hellboy reboot and I hope it will become
the path forward for if nothing else
just not taking away the the roles that
are actually written to be something
other than white people and and even if
we can get to the point where that stops
happening that doesn't mean
is solved that doesn't mean casting
disparities are solved because you know
there's still issues of proportional
representation there's still issues of
the fact that when we're talking about
non adapted works there's they're often
still written excessively why in and all
these other things which are not things
I want to tackle in this video so but it
what I'm talking about in terms of just
the studio's might finally be clicking
that this this thing taking these roles
away when there is the chance from a
source material to cast an ethnic
minority just cast that minority if we
could have that be the norm that's a
good first step towards getting a better
balance overall and just cutting through
the crap that that keeps happening all
the time so yeah I think I think I'm
done so those are my thoughts on this
whole sort of casting thing I don't want
to call it a controversy because like I
said it's been fairly civil at least in
terms of how it appears to have gone
down so yeah I just thought it was
interesting and like I said it's a topic
I've tackled before to my pain often
times when it comes to the comment
sections but I haven't tried away from
it before I'm not gonna shy away from it
now so there we go what were your
thoughts on this whole little thing that
happened whatever they are please keep
it polite but drop your thoughts down in
the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at Council with geeks
give a listen to the council of geeks
podcast feed I'm also one half of the
punch like your girl podcast both of
those available on iTunes and stitcher
it's not called iTunes anymore isn't it
is it Apple podcasts or whatever it is
it's available on there until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]